as I've already told you yesterday was
the biggest single-day decline in the
stock market in terms of points in the
history of the United States the biggest
percentage decline in 12 years dating
all the way back to 2008 Donald Trump
had an absolute and total meltdown as it
was happening Donald Trump's actions are
showing that he is afraid of what's
going on with the stock market and the
virus he's not shaking hands with people
he thinks journalists on Air Force One
are gonna try to infect him weaponizing
the virus and check out his Twitter
meltdown as futures were crashing
yesterday as the stock market was
imploding yesterday first before the
stock market opened at 9:30 a.m. Eastern
Time futures were collapsing futures are
a leading indicator of what the stock
market is expected to do during the day
a Donald Trump tweeting starting very
early in the morning quote the
obama-biden administration is the most
corrupt administration in the history of
our country this is of course untrue
compared to Trump's administration alone
but it's unrelated to what we at the
time suspected was going to be the
biggest single-day stock market decline
in history and it was on a point by
point basis then still in the pre-market
hours we can tell the stock market's
about to dive and Trump starts tweeting
about MSNBC or as he calls it MSDN see
quoting saying Trump has out mastered
the deep state he's light years ahead of
us MSDN see I disagree says Trump we
have a long way to go there are still
some very bad sick people in our
government people who do not love our
capital C country in fact they hate our
country the country is collapsing around
him we have a completely out-of-control
medical situation that he is way in over
his head in terms of being able to
handle and he's arguing with what a TV
network says and calling people haters
of the United States then he goes into
the Bernie Sanders material tweeting
quote now the Democrats are trying to
smear Bernie with Russia Russia Russia
they are driving him crazy older
Americans are in grave danger and this
is what he's doing
and this is what he's saying while
insisting everything on is under control
everything's fine nothing to see here
then the stock market actually is
imploding throughout the day so quickly
in fact that it triggered some failsafe
methods to halt trading in the middle of
the day and Donald Trump tweets quote
cryin Chuck Schumer said you will pay
the price for this you won't know what
hit you referring to Chuck Schumer's
comments about Supreme Court justices
that is far beyond simple rhetoric that
is a physical threat or at least a
threat that you better vote for us
trouble ahead
we had like 5,000 or more new virus
cases yesterday stocks declined so much
so quickly that fail-safes
are enacted and Donald Trump tweets the
fake news media and their partner the
Democrat Party is doing everything
within its Semmy considerable power it
used to be greater to inflame the virus
situation far beyond what the facts
would warrant surged in general the risk
is low to the average American people
are dying around him he has now been
around congressman Matt Gaetz who is in
self quarantine after coming into
someone who was carrying the virus at
CPAC and Trump is late to the game he's
not doing enough he doesn't understand
it or he pretends not to understand it
and all he cares about is media coverage
of him it is truly sick it's bad it's
horribly embarrassing and my real
concern is that other countries will
start to get this under control
China already has I don't know exactly
what's happening in Italy we're hopeful
then in the next 7 days new cases will
decline drastically in Italy now that
they have gone into a absolutely
over-the-top full lockdown
and by over-the-top I mean who would
have assumed this would ever happen
three months ago but it seems to be what
they have to do it's not over the top in
that sense it seems appropriately
calibrated to the nature of the of the
outbreak there I'm worried that it's
just gonna keep getting worse and worse
in the United States while it will
improve elsewhere and we will become the
problem we will be the ones not allowed
to travel to other
countries we will be the ones continuing
to suffer the consequences economic and
health of this because Donald Trump is
so underprepared and so in over his head
again
sick bad horrible embarrassing I don't
even think that those terms fully cover
it we are continuing to cover this and
other stories from today's program on
Instagram make sure you were following
the David Pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show and a little levity if
you're feeling down because of
everything that's going on and I
understand that I held a baby and a
picture of me holding a baby it's like a
loaf of bread or a football I'm holding
it it's on my Instagram page at David
Pakman follow me they are a quick break
much more coming up last night President
Donald Trump gave an emergency oval
office address about the virus the
speech confirmed two things primarily
Donald Trump is a liar and Donald Trump
is incompetent you probably knew both of
those things first of all just to get
the optics out of the way for some
reason Donald Trump's right eye seemed
almost completely swollen shut during
the entire nine minute speech his
breathing was also extremely labored the
left eye which was open seemed red and
odd so increasing suspicions that Donald
Trump himself may be sick whether it's
with the virus or not we don't know
that's the optics let's now get to the
substance which is the most important
thing most of the nine minutes was
Donald Trump either bragging about how
great he's done with the virus or
blaming other people for anything that
has hasn't gone the right way I'm not
even gonna play all of these examples
for you because they're pointless and
Stern in terms of actually protecting
ourselves but Donald Trump said that his
travel travel closures from China were
great now the truth is even after he
announced them which was very late
flight still continued flying in from
China for a while he said the power of
the United States to fight pandemics is
great it's almost like military language
like this is a military battle we're
going into he bragged about authorizing
eight billion dollars way too late by
the way after denying for awhile that we
need to do anything about this for a
response and then he also attacked the
European Union about how they did
act as quickly as he did they caused a
lot of the cases that we have here
it's Europe's fault let's look briefly
at the Europe attack and taking early
intense action we have seen dramatically
fewer cases of the virus in the United
States than are now present in Europe
the European Union failed to take the
same precautions and restrict travel
from China and other hotspots as a
result a large number of new clusters in
the United States were seated by
travelers from Europe he also used the
number of cases here which we know to be
false to claim that we don't have that
many cases the reality of course is we
haven't been testing because Donald
Trump completely bungled that as well
then on the policy stuff what is Trump
actually doing Trump was either
deceptive or clueless on almost every
single point Trump said travel from
Europe is now banned this was one of the
big points that he made after consulting
with our top government health
professionals I have decided to take
several strong but necessary actions to
protect the health and well-being of all
Americans to keep new cases from
entering our shores we will be
suspending all travel from Europe to the
United States for the next 30 days now a
lot of people thought wow okay I mean
it's a lot but this will stop
transmission to some degree we're
shutting down all travel to and from
Europe for everybody
however not only is the United Kingdom
exempted meaning you just have to get
yourself from wherever in Europe to the
UK and then fly to the United States
presumably you'll be asked about where
you're coming from but again that these
are not failsafe methods more
importantly the ban does not apply to
u.s. citizens or residents and u.s.
citizens or residents aren't banned from
flying to Europe and then simply coming
back this is just foreign nationals who
aren't allowed to come to the United
States the statement making that clear
which was released after the fact by the
administration and again as Donald Trump
said you can also get exemptions Donald
from also during this address last night
said the European
Boban also applies to trade and cargo
that was just not true the White House
had to correct that later and remember
Trump was reading all of this off of a
teleprompter these were not off-the-cuff
Mis statements from Donald Trump it was
on the prompter meaning either whoever
wrote the speech has absolutely no idea
what it is that's going on or they
decided let's just lie in order to make
this seem like something other than what
it is so you can argue about whether
this Europe thing is the right policy
but Trump presenting the policy one way
it's actually something completely
different immediately sending all sorts
of people into panic because they
misunderstood because of what Trump said
what the policy actually is another
example and this one is straight-up
insane Donald Trump said during the
address yesterday he met with health
insurance companies and they are waiving
all co-payments for coronavirus
treatments that's a big deal if it's
true listen to Donald Trump say it
earlier this week I met with the leaders
of health insurance industry who have
agreed to waive all co-payments for
coronavirus treatments extend insurance
coverage to these treatments and to
prevent surprise medical billing so
there it is Trump says insurance
companies are waiving all co-payments
for coronavirus treatment Wow
that's a big deal that's a really good
thing turns out it's a complete and
total lie
Donald Trump misstated it on national
television in front of the entire
country
we immediately afterwards heard from a
spokesperson for a hip a hip is a big
insurance health insurance company
lobbying group and they said no no no we
are waiving co-pays on testing for the
virus we are not waiving co-pays or
coinsurance or deductible requirements
for treatment this is something Trump
read off of a teleprompter and it was
not true
you can get tested without a copay even
though suppose we were told the tests
weren't gonna cost the end-user anything
anyway I don't even know why we need
that from insurance companies but you
have to often be tested for other things
first rule them out before you can be
tested for kovat if you do have the
virus and you
in treatment you will have to pay your
co-pays you will have to pay your
coinsurance if you have it if you first
have to meet your annual deductible you
will have to meet it that can be
thousands of dollars for many many
people so in short a speech about
something which Trump claimed is no big
deal but it still requires an emergency
9:00 p.m. Eastern Time speech to the
country riddled with lies and deception
and incompetence Trump also promised
some financial relief to people who are
either sick or quarantined or caring for
people who are also announced s small
business association loans add interest
to businesses those policies would
actually be good if they happen but
Trump lied his way through the entire
speech Trump also said he's proposing a
payroll tax cut through the end of the
year if that happens that could take a
while and Trump is refusing to meet with
Nancy Pelosi whose help he needs in
order to get that done we'll talk about
that a little bit later but the the sort
of the icing on the cake on a rotten
cake that is riddled with infections you
know the icing on the cake is to claim
insurance companies are waiving
treatment co-payments when they're not
that actually would be a really big deal
if they were doing it but it is not true
and Trump you know he takes the
political benefit of saying it most of
the country probably never hears the
correction that was untrue
where were the fact-checkers how does so
much misinformation get into a
teleprompter speech I don't know the
president's own speech was riddled with
fake news I've used the term weaponized
ignorant and weaponized narcissism
before when talking about Donald Trump
these have never been more relevant
terms than right now with the CV
situation we're calling it the cool
virus to avoid D monetization on YouTube
I think you guys remember CV the US has
not been testing people the US has done
as of early this past weekend only about
1800 total tests when you have at the
time it was 400 cases and you've only
done 2000 or 1800 tests you just don't
know how prevalent this is in the
general population but you are certainly
dramatically understating the number of
cases this is Donald Trump's fault
the whio made a test available which
Trump's CDC rejected they said we're
trying to make
our own test that failed and now we are
embarassingly behind on this issue Trump
went to the CDC in Atlanta people
started asking questions to the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Alex Azhar and the CDC doctor about the
lack of tests and Trump interrupts and
wildly claims without evidence because
it's a total lie that they have a test
that anyone who wants the test can get
it despite dr. Redfield from the CDC
saying well we have some tests we have a
limited number we've got to get him out
doctors from all over the country saying
we have no tests notice Trump's
attention deficit in full swing as well
looking around the room as the adults
talk until he decides to interrupt with
his disinformation dr. Redfield talk to
you they believe him you you won't
believe me we continued our first our
first responsibility CDC as I said was
developed the eyes the lab second
responsibility is to get that out to the
public health
and we now ship that I think anybody
that wants a test can get it yes that's
what we started so this is not true we
are so far behind on getting tests done
there are people with presumptive cases
not being tested and sent home we
haven't done any tests in broader
communities like South Korea has done
it's a mess now the the the part we're
not that I care about the politics but
that is interesting is that Trump would
benefit politically from having done way
more tests because it is almost
guaranteed that the death rate in the
u.s. is well below the international
death rate which is very heavily skewed
towards China and towards the beginning
of this when it appears you know that a
more chaotic situation led to inferior
treatment if Donald Trump had done a lot
more tests he would be able to say
listen we can trust that we know the
number of cases and our death rate is
really low that would help him
politically he may not even realize that
but it doesn't even matter he's lying
and that's what it what is important
here now in this next clip Trump claims
to have some kind of special ability on
medicine and medical related issues
apparently because his Uncle John Trump
taught at MIT
this is weaponized ignorance and weapon
weaponized narcissism John Trump was
some super genius so Trump says doctors
are regularly shocked by how much he
knows about medicine imagine what's
going on in this guy's head I've seen
what they've done back there it's really
addressed
by the way NIH what they've done I spend
time over there
like the stuff you know my uncle it's a
great mercy was at MIT he taught at MIT
for I think like a record number of
years he was a great super genius dr.
John Trump I like this stuff I really
get it was surprised about understand
every one of these thought you said how
do you know so much about this maybe I
have a natural ability maybe I should
have done that instead of running to
principle but you know what but they've
done it's really incredible I understand
that whole world
[Music]
they should be given tremendous credit
and the whole world is relying on us
can you imagine Trump praising himself
for how much he knows about medicine
claims doctors are impressed with his
medical knowledge meanwhile we can't
even test people for the cool virus
because we have barely any tests and
then here's the icing on the cake of
incompetence when Secretary of Health
and Human Services as our is trying to
explain the truth about the tests Trump
interrupts and says the tests are
beautiful
the tests are beautiful thanks a million
tests so they shipped 700 thousand
already the remaining Lots are actually
being tested here dr. Monroe's got them
as what I think 10:30 this morning and
they have to do the quality control and
then if they pass but but I think I
think anybody right now and yesterday
anybody that needs a test gets a test me
there there they have the tests and the
tests of you
anybody that needs a testing gets a test
if there's a doctor that wants to test
if there's somebody coming off the ship
like the big monster ship that's out
there right now which you know again
that's a big decision I won't bring all
those people long so there it is Trump
says it it's a beautiful test has anyone
ever seen a beautiful virus test what
does that even mean and you just know
Trump is lying and clueless and in way
over his head when he starts calling
tests beautiful when he starts calling
anything beautiful remember he said
we're gonna replace Obamacare with a
beautiful system never happened turned
out that the only thing he proposed
would have led to 20 or 30 million more
people losing their health insurance
we're in trouble and I want to talk more
about the testing thing because it's not
just indifference Trump's refusal to use
the World Health Organization test
starting a while ago is actually
responsible for a more quickly growing
outbreak than we'd otherwise have so we
tend to take the news day by day here we
look at each element of what has taken
place we analyze it for its factual
substrate and we can textual eyes the
news in history or society or culture or
the economy or science or whatever is
warranted by what's taking place we're
sort of at the endpoint here with Donald
Trump we have a president who simply
can't do his job and Donald Trump is
long past the moment where he should
resign the presidency of the United
States because the pandemic crisis that
Donald Trump is dealing with or better
said not dealing with has proven that he
can't lead he can't handle this and we
already suspected that we many of us on
the left we already knew that before but
it should really be clear to anyone
who's willing to apply the most minut
amount of critical thinking at this
point he has mishandled it with lies and
delays and ignorant and incompetence
from day one and people are dying and
the pandemic is spreading and to really
understand this you actually have to go
back years when Donald Trump expressed
back during the Republican primary in
2015 vaccine
kepta sysm he's not an anti-vaxxer but
expect express fact free unscientific
vaccine skepticism that was a sign that
this guy was not playing with a full
deck then he became president of the
United States he disbanded the pandemic
response team why would anyone do that
the medical field knows that there are
you know hundred year flus there's the
idea of thousand year viruses it's just
a matter of time until we're faced with
one trump disbands the pandemic response
team cuts funding to the CDC so you have
a cluelessly
vaccine skeptical guy disbanding the
pandemic response team and cutting CDC
funding nothing's happened yet at that
point but it's already bad then this
starts to spread out of China Trump does
nothing for a while says it's all fine
it's all gonna go away starts to get
weird then he makes completely reckless
baseless predictions about we won't
really have cases than we have them
we're not going to have deaths than we
have them there was never any basis in
fact or science in any of those
predictions
On February 29th Trump said the closest
he said the number of people infected in
the US would soon be close to zero that
of course was irresponsible and it was
untrue Trump said it's sort of like the
flu Trump says medical experts should
stop speaking publicly he muzzles people
from talking he's clearly in over his
head but then it really gets bad Trump
bungles testing initially rejecting the
WH o--'s test because the CDC was going
to create one CDC fails Trump continues
to brag about how low the number of
cases here is the reason the number is
low is because we aren't testing now
realistically if we were testing right
now we wouldn't have 1,400 cases we
would have anywhere from you know on the
very low end now three thousand eight
nine thousand depending on which
estimate you look at Trump appoints Mike
Pence to run this entire thing a guy who
is almost as clueless as Trump combined
with the weaponization of Mike Pence is
evangelical Christianity which once led
him to pray about what he should do
about an HIV outbreak that was ravaging
his state of Indiana when he was
governor there and then the cherry on
top
Trump is attacking journalists like
cNN's Jim Acosta for asking him
questions about his failed response
while insisting it's not serious Trump
does an emergency presidential Oval
Office national address during which he
incorrectly states almost every measure
being taken says we have a Europe travel
ban except it really only applies to
foreign nationals coming to the United
States not Americans who want to go back
and forth to their heart's content says
the ban does apply to cargo and trade
when it doesn't and most shockingly most
damaging claims that insurance companies
are waiving all co-payments for virus
treatment when that is not true and
insurance companies Ameet within minutes
of Trump speech immediately come out and
say that's not true we're not waiving
any co-pays on treatment the man can't
handle it he is in over his head he must
resign he never will of course but he
should his narcissism has been
weaponized and combined with his
ignorant his delusions of grandeur he is
building a public health crisis through
his actions Republicans and the people
around him are enabling him to continue
doing it and lastly Trump may also be
sick himself I know you know that it may
not be the virus but Trump's been in
contact with people exposed to the virus
he could have anything it could be the
flu it could be something else last
night during Trump's address his right
eye was almost swollen shut his
breathing was labored his left eye which
was open was red and shiny and a
Brazilian official that Trump hung out
with over the weekend at mar-a-lago is
now suspected of having the virus
himself that's totally separate from
Trump's incompetence by the way at this
point it's just a side note anyone other
than Trump would be handling this more
competently the owner of the barber shop
down the street
from me I would be be more comfortable
with him handling this than Trump
because he wouldn't bring the chip on
his shoulder that Trump brings that
makes him think he knows everything and
not listen to any of the experts the
owner of the travel agency in my
neighborhood who at least understands
how viruses spread through travel right
anyone would be better suited to deal
with this than
is Donald from today it is a national
nightmare and I don't know what the
eventual outcome is going to be I I you
know for me this is not political in the
sense that if Trump put together
tomorrow a great plan turn this around
and things start going in the right
direction I would gladly say this is
life and death for people I don't care
Republican Democrat Trump whoever that's
all I want the observations I'm making
are not based on Trump's political party
membership or anything other than this
is a fiasco it is hard to find a country
dealing with this more poorly than
Donald Trump is luckily there are enough
health professionals at lower levels
around the country that they are making
some of the right decisions even without
Donald Trump's involvement help or
direction that's what's saving us at
this point in time national nightmare
almost doesn't even cover it we've said
many times Donald Trump doesn't appear
to ever show empathy for anyone if I
were the victim of a tragedy the last
person I would want comforting me would
be Donald Trump and there's incredible
new video of Donald Trump learning that
the family of an eight year old boy was
killed and Trump shows no emotion
whatsoever and focuses on the cartoonish
nature of an eight-year-old getting
sucked up by a tornado
Trump having almost no reaction
whatsoever that the to the news that the
boy's family was killed the kid is now
an orphan his parents were killed his
sister was killed
but Trump continuing to do the cyclone
motion with his hand in video I will
show you and talk about just the
remarkable nature of somebody being
sucked up by a tornado
this happened in Tennessee which had
horrible tornado last week Trump flew
down to meet some of the families
imagine that imagine suffering tragedy
and Trump shows up to greet you and come
for you Trump stood in front of houses
that were totally destroyed by the
tornadoes and just fixated on the story
of this one kid and again Trump showing
no emotion whatsoever during the video
you'll see Trump fixated on the kid
being picked up by the tornado asks what
happened to the parents is told the
parents were killed the sister was
killed and he says oh okay well the
tornado just sucked the kid up
it seems almost like the family dying is
an irrelevant aside oh the family was
killed the kid was sucked up and Trump
doing this cyclone motion with his hand
take a look there was one case though I
heard the government was a 8 year old
boy was ripped out flown to a certain
area and dropped off at the street two
or three blocks away and they found him
walking and he said I just flew in the
air and he was walking down the street
two blocks away from himself and how did
this parents do
[Music]
so it took him and he said I was carried
by the air away from my house and his
parents were killed and his sister so
we're gonna go see some of the folks a
kid was sucked into a tornado flung down
the street his family died and Trump is
obsessed with the tornado itself sucking
the kid up and seems completely unmoved
by the death of the entire family he's
talking about it like some kind of
novelty he keeps making that cyclonic
twirling motion with his hands after
being told everybody died but kids
family is dead and Trump no condolences
it's not even sure it's not even clear
you know if if some reaction even if he
doesn't know what to say that shows some
empathy acknowledged the tragic sadness
of a kid who's now an orphan after being
thrown around by a tornado and again I
got emails from from people saying David
this is video that proves Trump's a bad
person or David this is video that
proves Trump has dementia this is
cognitive decline I don't know guys I
don't know what it is I can't figure it
out lack of empathy seems to be clearly
a part of it it's really really bad
though and it reminded me of when a baby
survived the mass shooting in Texas
while Trump was president the entire
babies family was killed this was an
orphaned baby and Trump staged a picture
with the baby after having the baby
brought back to the hospital with
Melania holding the baby and Trump
grinning ear-to-ear with a thumbs up the
most fabricated photo op using a baby as
a complete and total prop and again
showing the total lack of empathy the
tornado video shows the exact same thing
it's just a disgusting terrible person
there's nothing new there using an
orphaned infant as a prop later just
retelling over and over while doing the
cyclone motion with his hand about a kid
sucked up by a tornado and at this point
if you're appalled by Trump's behavior
you
surprised by Trump's behavior you're not
paying attention what we should be
shocked disgusted and appalled by is
that 40% of our neighbors here in the
United States statistically still
condone this
they still support this and probably
close to half of the population that
plans to vote in November is going to
vote for four more years of this that's
where we should be focusing our
discussed at this point because it is
disgusting
we will likely have the video we played
and more coverage of this on the David
Pakman show
instagram page at david pakman show
follow our page there we will take a
quick break and be right back after this
Donald Trump has an economic advisor
named Larry Kudlow Larry Kudlow is a
right winger he occasionally will say
something uncontroversial that just kind
of makes sense but very often Larry
Kudlow says outrageous things that don't
make any sense Larry Kudlow also used to
have an addiction problem with both
cocaine and alcohol and there have been
a number of recent appearances where it
has been speculated that Kudlow seems
drunk Kudlow recently appeared on CNBC
he of course downplayed virus fears and
suggested during the interview that
America stay at work he also sounded
completely drunk as if Donald Trump and
Mike Pence being clueless on this issue
was not bad enough alone here's Larry
Kudlow listen to him slurring seems to
pause a few times to burp
it's a very strange video well I'm not
sure where you're going on that look
immediately in January against the
advice of a lot of health professionals
president Trump automatically put on
travel bans with respect to China and
then we instituted quarantines for the
people Americans coming back from China
and foreign nationals it continues to
get worse Kudlow number one making no
sense but number two sounding impaired
here he is saying America should stay at
work if you're healthy you should go to
work go batshit business
that's our advice and even regarding
transportation you know which maybe hit
the airlines and they were very calm
about it but they're in trouble and some
of their numbers look domestic flight
for the most part is in good shape and
if you stay away from some of the travel
warning countries international flight
likewise so I don't want to downplay
anything we worry about them Tecton
human beings forever say but I'm just
saying that's not over at work we should
stay and then as the interview continues
just sounding more and more slurry
although slurry is something else slur
like maybe is a better term help
professions that I speak to Scott
Gottlieb the former FDA Commissioner
would say very different things in
particular about Seattle and about the
government response that needs to
actually take place and how we need to
be a lot more formidable in our response
and statements like the ones you just
got actually brings actually encouraging
people got ratings that they shouldn't
and that will actually cause the spread
of the virus as opposed to it stopping
it I don't that's not what looks [ __ ]
out leaves a brain guy and he's friend
of mine with respect to Seattle all
right that would be a place you will
avoid for now and gavin newsom governor
Newsom declaring a California emergency
state especially Northern California I
understand that avoid it listen Scott
God leaves a friend of mine I respect
the guy this does not sound normal
ladies and gentlemen it is very strange
stuff and I have to tell you I'm all in
favor of the do not panic type of stuff
panic on top of whatever the facts are
it never makes a situation better
there's no question about that and again
I believe the death rate is far lower
than what is being reported for the
United States for Post February one
cases I believe there are likely tons of
people that aren't even in the numbers
who are having super mild cases of the
virus the problem is that with this
administration it's don't panic we don't
have any cases
and then we get cases so then they have
to say well listen don't panic we
haven't had any deaths because we're so
prepared and then we get deaths and then
it's don't panic
we have very few new cases and then
yesterday we had more new cases than
China which increasingly seems to have
it under control and is dropping the
number of active cases by one to two
thousand every single day then it's
don't panic we have the tests but we
actually don't have the tests they
simply can't be believed about any of
this period and so when Larry Kudlow
shows up sounding drunk seeming impaired
and says well I think we should probably
stay at work and you know this is all
overblown and the president knows what
he's doing and pens no no they don't
know what they're doing Mike Pence who
tried to pray when he was dealing with
an HIV crisis in his state of Indiana is
the guy that's running this entire thing
and by the way we learned over the
weekend that so CPAC was last week or
the week before there was an attendee at
CPAC who shook hands with Matt slap that
attendee has the virus Matt slap then
shook hands and was on stage for a while
with both Trump and pence now the timing
of it does not suggest that they were
infected Ted Cruz was also involved in
that Ted Cruz says out of an abundance
of caution he is self quarantine until a
full 14 days have passed since that
handshake an event took place is it
possible that as it encroaches on them
they will take it more seriously and it
you know it's sort of like when you have
an anti-gay politician that changes
their mind when they find out their kid
is gay and we say well they came around
to the right position but it's really a
startling lack of empathy that they were
only able to change their mind when it
affected them rather than being able to
say well let me imagine what it would be
like if I had a gay kid right or a kid
who's part of the LGBT community in much
the same way it would be great whatever
causes this administration to start
taking this seriously
it's sad because of the lack of empathy
that it confirms that it depends on
Trump
pens shaking hands with someone that was
exposed to somebody carrying the virus
and/or of course the idea that Trump
realizes this might have a political
implication I'd better get it together
it's sad but if that's what it takes to
get them to take it seriously I'll still
accept it I hate to be saying this and I
really hope that I'm wrong but we may
now be on the precipice of the global
recession that we anticipated would
eventually come we didn't know when but
one of the inherent elements of our
system is the persistent booms and busts
there's always some downturn some
recession around the corner we just
don't know how many blocks we are from
turning the corner so to speak right now
the stock market is open as we are
producing today's show just 9 minutes in
the stock market dropped by so much in
the United States that it triggered some
protective measures which shut down
trading immediately in the United States
ten minutes later stocks reopened at
9:50 a.m. Eastern Time and the stocks
have been up and down all day today
could be could be the greatest single
day decline in stock market history on a
points basis not on a percentage basis
it may reverse before the end of the day
we don't know but as of right now we
could have the largest one-day point
decline in the history of our stock
market in addition to this the oil
market has crashed oil prices fell as
much as 34% and stabilized down about
21% again as of right now this
information may change by the time you
listen to today's show or watch this
clip Saudi Arabia and Russia are now in
a growing price war this is the most
that oil prices have fallen in decades
then they stabilize down about 21% and
those numbers will continue to change
over the weekend Russia refused to say
how much oil they are producing they
were asked to make some commitments in
order to stabilize the market Russia
refused to say how much oil they're
producing Saudi Arabia in response then
drastically cut prices this caused world
markets to crash the UK footsie 100
index was down 7% as of a couple hours
ago
American stock markets also down and
then of course on top of all of this we
have the growing virus situation which
we have been covering extensively and
will cover later on today and I know you
all know about as well so listen we may
be at the start of a massive global
recession which if indeed is starting
now it could be years before we get back
to the price levels of the stock market
of a month ago now the stock market
doesn't affect everybody at least not
directly and to be clear I hope it
doesn't happen every time I tweet about
the economy I get tweets from followers
who say Oh David you're just begging for
an economic crash so that Donald Trump
gets politically hurt aren't you no I'm
not I've made that clear I don't want
people losing their jobs
I don't want stocks crashing I don't
want anyone to die from the virus I'm
not a terrible person so I don't want
horrible things to happen just so that
people realize that Donald Trump is an
incompetent buffoon and to be frank if
you've not already realized Donald Trump
is an incompetent buffoon the stock
market crashing or the virus spreading
or whatever else is not going to
convince those people it would be a
futile effort if that's what I'm
counting on it would be both morally
wrong and misguided based on the facts
what I want to focus on is look at how
quickly things can go into the trash in
a period of 7 to 8 weeks if there is any
bigger picture message here it's that of
the inherent fragility of our system
this is partially about the inherent
nature of the economic system we have it
is fragile we've learned food supply
lines are more fragile than we think
markets are more fragile than we think
the medical system is fragile it quickly
becomes overwhelmed when something like
the virus starts to spread ventilators
are at are in short supply hospital beds
are in short supply panicked people buy
masks they don't even need causing a
shortage for health care workers who
actually do need them for as long as our
economic system remains fundamentally
what it is now this fragility will
always exist and in fact the booms and
the busts are part of the system we've
been
talking about this for years as far as
the micro what's the stock market doing
today what is the response of our
completely misguided and ignorant
administration in terms of the virus we
will see how that shakes out today we
will see how it shakes out tomorrow if
indeed this is the start of a global
recession once again it could be years
before we get back to the point where we
were just two months ago but for as long
as our economic system remains
fundamentally what it is right now these
fragile sort of awakenings the awakening
of the fragility of the system will keep
cropping up because the system is
fragile that's the reality that's not
advocating for prepping that's not
advocating for communism it's the
reality of the version of the capitalist
system that we have and of so many other
things that we've been talking about as
well